want to get remember i told you i had
something about the steelers i wanted to
get to with you
yeah this this story just keeps yeah
have you been following this story so
yes i am the steelers agree yeah going
into week one for those that don't know
the still has agreed
um to wear the name of
el antoine rose jr a black teenager
killed by east pittsburgh police in 2018
on the backs of their helmets they
agreed as a team to do that for the
entire 2020 season
al villanueva who is an army ranger
very pro-military as you know and a
couple of years back when the rest of
the team stayed in the locker room
he came out in the tunnel with his hand
on his heart for the national anthem
he covered up rose's name and wrote um
army sergeant first class alwyn cashe's
name
on the back of his helmet he's a black
soldier who was killed on duty in iraq
and posthumously awarded the silver star
for heroism now come to find out this is
where it
really gets interesting is marquis
pouncey today put on instagram
basically what amounted to an apology if
not a declaration that blue lives matter
he said i want to personally clarify
what transpired this past monday night
in regards to having antoine rose's name
on the back of a helmet
he talked about the uh limited
information
that he claims to have gotten regarding
the situation he decided his work with
police
he was like moving forward i will make
my own decision about what to wear in
the back of my helmet
so now you have building a waiver
breaking ranks you've got policy
breaking ranks
and you have them both deflecting from
the conversation
and conflating what the conversation is
really about michael holland what's your
take on this yeah
okay this is what i think of it one
i kind of respect this aspect of it it
they just got there a little they got
there in a in a uh
in a very securities way uh big words
here
big circuitous ooh uh but they got there
in a in a backwards way look
we can't pretend like all of these teams
are just going to be
on board and all agree
on these iss on these issues that we we
don't all agree on
so why even try to do it don't do it
you're either going to go all
in as a team and say is everybody cool
with this
is everybody all right because this is
what we're going to do
if you have dissent from three people
four people or two people in this case
it's just better to move away from it
so that let's just that's not what
happened here though michael
i know why no but they what they did is
and this is why i don't like i i can't
stand workplaces like this
i think what happened is they agree they
all agreed to do it right
they all they all agree building their
way off guard he's surprised
there's a little back door i can't stand
that i can't stand that let's be real
let's be real about it i hate it when
people
say okay when they nod their heads and
nod their heads like they're feeling you
and then they take another round yeah i
will respect you more
even if i don't agree with you because
i'm a up
i know you're not going to see
everything the same way i see it
but at least be straight up with me and
say
well i don't like that i don't i don't
want to do that with my helmet and if
you do that
i think it's just better and you go in
another direction
as a team here's the other thing i want
to say yeah yeah go ahead
with pouncey he raised more questions
for me
with his instagram post than he did shut
down some man uh shut down some issues
he said there there's limited
information well i read the story just
like he did
what am i missing yeah it was it was a
rookie it was a rookie cop
on the job for three weeks cop says
he didn't know he thought somebody had a
gun we've heard this story before
thought somebody had a gun didn't shoot
he wasn't sure who had the gun
he shot this uh young man three times in
the back
yeah what am i missing he was acquitted
is that the information that's out there
and and
and quite frankly we've seen that story
before too a lot of times
you had these police shootings the
shooter has been acquitted
so marquis pouncey tell me this
in your next post so i can be educated
what is the missing information
that you have and the rest of us don't
yeah
look an information that's my challenge
that's my challenge to him give me the
information yeah
and i'll continue information too often
times nowadays is
is often subjective and shaky for policy
like i said this was basically opposed
to saying blue lives matter
uh policy and let me preface it by
saying i respect
law enforcement um generally speaking
um but policy is a guy that thinks that
the answer to police brutality
is is ride-alongs he thinks the answer
to police brutality
is let me support the police so pouncey
and he does he does a lot of work with
florida police
and and i get pittsburgh and pittsburgh
police as well and pittsburgh
and pittsburgh i get his affection for
for law enforcement i know his family
history and this that and the other but
okay man
it's like we're talking about police
police brutality
and it's a subtle and yet
popular and uh and and you know frequent
attempt
you know to deflect from
the police the issue of police brutality
by
now taking the side of of law
enforcement and saying well they have
such a tough job
or you know what it's it's it's it's the
same old trait it's from the place from
the playbook that we've seen
years and you for years and years now
when it comes to like hey man
you know that's your this is not just
him
making an individual decision this is
him intentionally running
counter to what your teams have agreed
to and what the conversation is
we're talking about police brutality
right it does exist it does happen
and now from somewhere he's got some
information like you're talking about
and now he's decided oh i'm sorry let me
come out
and make clear where i stand on this
issue
which is hey we got to do a better job
of supporting cops now we got to do a
better job
of getting rid of getting rid of killer
cops is what we have to do a better job
of so that's my
that's my pouncy thing and holding them
accountable that's my pouncy part
villanueva villanueva you know we talked
about the town earlier be slicker than a
six-year-old let me be clear man
nothing but respect for people in our
military nothing but respect people are
military i respect feeling the wave
thank you for his service but this is
feeding into the conflation of the black
lives matter movement and specifically
the player-led protests started by colin
kaepernick in 2016
of kneeling during the national anthem
in peaceful protests against the issue
of police brutality
this is the practice of conflating that
with some kind of anti-military stance
and because again rest in peace to
sergeant first class alwyn cashe rest in
peace and he gave his life for our
country
but supporting antoine rose jr
has nothing to do with a fallen soldier
and so now you're bringing in a military
commentary into this situation by by
honoring him
in other words saying no i'm not gonna
honor the victim of police brutality
which is what we all agreed to do
as a team or what this conversation is
about i'm gonna bring the military into
it which is that classic play
that people have been doing for years
now conflating
the uh kneeling near the practice of
kneeling during that national anthem
with some kind of anti-military stance i
said this last week michael i said at
the beginning this week we talked about
you know the week one demonstrations we
cannot get unity
and consensus we can't get those two
things mixed up there will not be unity
and consist
consensus in this issue teamwork is not
going to make this particular dream work
that's not going to happen because what
you have right now
is guys in that locker room we talked
about mike tomlin and his ability to
manage personalities
guys in that locker room are now going
their separate ways doing their own
thing
and that's a lot of things i think
that's a lot of conversation
i think that's a lot of teams i think
that's a lot of people not not just
football but
in in industries uh across north america
but i would say this very quickly
and this is something that we will
bookmark and keep talking about because
it's not going away it's an issue that's
not going away
i think but if you really if i had to
find a common denominator
all of this commentary and hey well what
about this what about that
it is this notion i think a misguided
notion
that to be critical of something is to
be against it
no i can be critical of it my family
my country my workplace
what did baldwin say i love my country
and therefore i reserve the right to
criticize her perpetually
i can be critical of it and still love
it
i can i can point out a flaw in it
without bringing down the entire
industry
i'm a journalist i feel no i feel no
um i feel no obligation
to defend steven glass who made up stuff
i felt no obligation to defend jason
blair who made up stuff
this that should not happen they they
they invented characters they invented
stories they invented quotes
they were journalists they were bad
journalists probably good writers but
bad journalists
so do i love journalism yes i do but you
can still be critical of of something
that is not right in your profession so
if you are in law enforcement
and you do the job well god bless you i
love you i respect you
you are necessary but you can also
be critical of your profession when your
profession has gone left
and let me also i can't say god laughing
because then that becomes political well
has gone askew
okay let me be fair in his in policy's
post he also says systemic racism issues
have occurred in our country for too
long and that needs to stop
my focus will continue to be on helping
the police in our communities and our
support making any necessary changes to
help those efforts he said make no
mistake i'm against racism
and the best thing we can do to continue
helping repair relationships
uh between the police and their
communities so
look all i'm saying is like these two
acts to me
undermine a conversation which frankly
shouldn't be a conversation
as in my humanity people that look like
me our humanity is not a conversation
it's not up for discussion
but when you do stuff like this it just
only serves
to deflect from what the real issue is
again
rest in peace army service sergeant
first class alwyn cashe i get
you know him being killed on duty in
iraq i get that but they had agreed as a
team
to honor a victim of police brutality
and for villanueva
to do his own thing and offer pouncer to
come back and claim that he got
information you're also making the rest
of your team look as though they don't
know what they're talking about
you're hurting the credibility of the
calls that your team took up
so anyway hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports